>> WITHOUT THE WALL?
>> NO.
THERE WOULDN'T BE.
>> THE WALL HAS TO BE THERE.
>> YOU NEED IT.
JOHN, YOU NEED THE WALL.
I MEAN, IT'S WONDERFUL.
I WOULD LOVE NOT TO BUILD
THE WALL BUT YOU NEED THE
THE ICE OFFICERS AND THE
BORDER PATROL AGENTS, I HAD
THE WALL, YOU KNOW, IN
CERTAIN AREAS, OBVIOUSLY,
THAT AREN'T PROTECTED BY
SECURITY.
JUST CAN'T HAVE IT.
IT DOESN'T WORK.
>> Sean: GOT IT.
WELCOME BACK TO HANNITY HERE
WITH REACTION TO MY OPENING
MONOLOGUE AND THE
PRESIDENT'S BIG BIPARTISAN
MEETING ON IMMIGRATION AT
THE WHITE HOUSE TODAY
COUNSEL TO THE PRESIDENT
KELLYANNE CONWAY IS BACK.
GOOD TO SEE YOU, KELLYANNE.
HERE THE PRESIDENT PUT OUT
THIS TWEET EARLIER TONIGHT
AND HE SAID BUILDING THE
WALL AND WE HEARD HIM OVER
AND OVER AGAIN.
FRIENDS OF MINE, THEY DOUBT
BECAUSE THEY HAVE BEEN
PROMISED AGAIN AND AGAIN AND
AGAIN.
WE ALWAYS GET THE
CONSIDERATION AMNESTY, NEVER
THE WALL.
WALL.
THEY WANT TO SEE SOME OF IT
BY NOVEMBER.
>> EVERYONE IN THAT ROOM
TODAY, EVERYONE WATCHING NOW
KNOWS WHERE THE PRESIDENT
STANDS ON THE WALL.
HE JUST REPEATED IT FOR YOU.
LIVE AND IN PERSON IN FRONT
OF THE ENTIRE WORLD TO SEE,
SEAN.
>> Sean: YEP.
CLEAR TODAY BECAUSE HE HAS
FRONT LINES WHO WANT THIS
WALL.
HE ASKED THE ICE AGENTS.
HE ASKED THE BORDER PATROL
LINE WHAT THEY WANT.
SECRETARY NIELSEN HAS ASKED
HER FOLKS WHAT DO YOU NEED
TO BE ABLE TO DO YOUR JOB TO
MAKE US A MORE SAFE AND
SECURE NATION.
THEY HAVE ALL SAID WE NEED
THIS TYPE OF SECURE -- WE
NEED A BORDER.
WE HAVE SPENT BILLIONS OF
DOLLARS OVER DECADES HELPING
OTHER COUNTRIES SECURE THEIR
OWN BORDERS, THEIR OWN
OUR COUNTRY AND THIS IS THE
I THINK IN THE SPAN OF ONE
HOUR TODAY, YOU SAW IN FULL
THE THREE MAJOR PROMISES
THIS PRESIDENT HAS MADE TO
TRANSPARENCY.
THE TRANSPARENCY IS OBVIOUS.
EVEN SOME OF HIS GREATEST
CRITICS IN THE MEDIA WERE
FLABBERGASTED, REALLY
STUNNED BUT APPRECIATIVE
THAT THIS PRESIDENT HELD
FORTH ON CAMERA FOR A FULL
HOUR WITH NO FILTER, NO
SCRIPT FOR ANYBODY.
JUST A CONVERSATION
BICAMERAL, BIPARTISAN,
UNPRECEDENTED IN THAT WAY IN
FIRST OBLIGATION IS TO KEEP
US SAFE AND SECURE IN THIS
COUNTRY.
DO YOU THAT WITH THE WALL.
THE SOUTHERN BORDER IS
2,000 MILES, ABOUT 800 OR SO
MIGHT BE THE PHYSICAL WALL.
THERE ARE MOUNTAINOUS AND
RIVER AREAS WHERE YOU CAN'T
PUT A PHYSICAL STRUCTURE BUT
YOU CAN PUT FENCING.
YOU CAN PUT MORE AGENTS
THERE IT MAKES US MORE SAFE
AND SECURE.
PEOPLE ARE ALREADY NOT
CROSSING AS MUCH AS THEY DID
ILLEGALLY BECAUSE THIS MAN
IS PRESIDENT.
BECAUSE THEY KNOW WALLS ARE
BEING BUILT.
BECAUSE THEY KNOW FOLKS ARE
TOUGHER.
WE DON'T WANT THE POISONOUS
DRUGS COMING OVER OUR
BORDER.
WE DON'T WANT PEOPLE COMING
IN TRAIN MIGRATION AND VISA
LOTTERY.
FINALLY PROSPERITY.
ECONOMIC SECURITY AND
NATIONAL SECURITY GO HAND IN
HAND.
YOU SEE WHAT'S HAPPENING
WITH THIS PRESIDENT.
HIS LEADERSHIP, HIS BOLD
THAT MASSIVE TAX CUT FOR THE
MIDDLE CLASS.
THEY ARE MAKING THIS COUNTRY
MORE PROSPEROUS.
AFRICAN-AMERICANS FOR TEENS,
FOR HISPANICS, FOR WOMEN,
NATIONAL SECURITY ECONOMIC
THE DEMOCRATS CAME THERE
TODAY BASICALLY SAYING DACA
IS NOT NEGOTIABLE.
DACA CONSIDERED THE WALL.
9.3 MILLION RESETTLED IN THE
POPULATION A YEAR.
ONE PERSON COMES HERE AND
YOU GET ABOUT SEVEN FAMILY
MEMBERS.
SOME COUNTRIES SEND UPWARDS
OF 20 FAMILY MEMBERS.
IT HAS TO STOP.
>> Sean: WHEN I SHOWED THE
TAPE OF CHUCK SCHUMER AND
BERNIE SANDERS AND HILLARY
CLINTON AND THEN THERE IS
BARACK OBAMA.
>> YEAH.
SOUND LIKE DONALD TRUMP.
NOW BECAUSE DONALD TRUMP
SUPPORTS IT THEY CAN'T
POSSIBLY SUPPORT ONLY IF THE
ANOINTED ONE, OBAMA.
MAYBE IF OPRAH SUPPORTED IT,
THEY WOULD SUPPORT IT.
IS IT JUST OPPOSITION TO
THIS PRESIDENT FOR THE SAKE
OF OPPOSITION?
AND THE OTHER POINT IS ALL
LEADING, OPENING UP
AND THAT'S WHAT MADE IT SO
FASCINATING.
>> IT WAS.
AND THOSE OF US WHO WORK
THERE SEE THAT EVERY DAY ON
A REGULAR BASIS.
HE REALLY ENJOYS A
DISCUSSION.
HE WELCOMES DISSENT AND HE
WELCOMES DISCUSSION.
THIS PRESIDENT TAKES MANY
DECISION.
HE WAS THE ONE ELECTED HERE
AFTER ALL.
DISPLAY TODAY IS VERY
HOUSE.
LET ME JUST SAY THIS.
WHEN YOU ASK WHAT'S
DIFFERENT NOW, SURE, WHAT'S
DIFFERENT FOR THESE
DEMOCRATS INCLUDING HILLARY
CLINTON, THEY ARE CROWING
AND BRAGGING ABOUT HOW MUCH
SHE DOESN'T THINK WE SHOULD
HAVE PEOPLE CROSSING
ILLEGALLY AND WE SHOULD HAVE
BORDERS.
WOW, SHE SHOULD HAVE SAID
THAT IN 2015, SHE MIGHT HAVE
MADE.
ANYWAY.
THE FACT IS THAT WHAT'S
WILLING TO ACTUALLY DO IT.
AND JUST LIKE WITH THESE TAX
CUTS, JUST LIKE WITH MOVING
THE EMBASSY TO JERUSALEM,
PEOPLE HAVE PROMISED BUT
THEY NEVER THOUGHT THEY
WOULD HAVE A PRESIDENT WHO
INTERESTS.
THIS IS A PRESIDENT TALKING
ABOUT NATIONAL INTERESTS NOT
SPECIAL INTERESTS.
>> Sean: LAST QUESTION,
PROMISE.
20300 MILES OF THE WALL DONE
NOW.
TAKE A LOOK AT IT WE MEANT
IT WE GOT IT DONE.
>> NO DOUBT.
WE DIDN'T GET HERE
OVERNIGHT.
WE KNOW THE WALL CAN'T BE
BUILT OVERNIGHT.
PEOPLE SEEING THAT IT IS
HAPPENING, THAT YOU HAVE A
PHYSICAL WALL, YOU ALSO HAVE
TECHNOLOGY, HAVE YOU FENCING
MOST IMPORTANTLY, YOU END
THE CHAIN MIGRATION, THE
DIVERSITY VISA LOTTERY AND
YOU SHOW PEOPLE SOUTHERN
BORDER WE HAVE MORE ICE
AGENTS THERE.
WE NEED TO EMPOWER THESE MEN
AND WOMEN WITH THE TOOLS
THEY NEED TO DO THEIR JOB.